and you date a boxer uh I know I'm a  fighter demi lovato chatting about her  man gear me Vasconcelos on Wednesdays  Ellen would you get nervous when he's in  the ring yeah of course  24-year old recently shared at this  video of them in the ring together  Demi also chatted about her sizzling  skin-tight Grammy dress at first I tried  on the dress and I was like I'm not  wearing this it's see-through and my  stylist was like but it looks amazing  and then everyone was like it looks  amazing and then I convinced myself but  I was actually on the red carpet with my  dad and that was awkward a dad do you  approve of the outfit yesterday  yesterday the former Disney star also  joked about losing to Adele at the award  show my mom is like you know that Adele  is gonna win this that's like  thanks mom yeah but way to stay positive  hey listen elections are crazy  and so I thought maybe I have a shot  yeah I was praying with the Russians  right  you